hello good evening
and Welcome to our
session on how to
start a career in business analytics uh
business analysis
with the University of Minnesota Carlson
School of Management my name is Stuart
Creek
a manager here at simply learn we're the
delivery partner with Carlson
and we'll be
hearing today from
Professor Motrin Yang and our instructor
Brian Campbell some material that we
recorded in an earlier session in August
so we'll be covering a few things today
about
you with some polls that will run during
the session we'll also be talking about
business analysis careers you'll hear
from Professor Yang and Brian on that
subject
um we'll talk about how what the program
offers and how it gets you job ready for
a business analysis career we'll cover
enrollment steps and we'll take some of
your questions
I've got some of the questions that
Professor Yang and Brian answered but
we'll also take some of your questions
live and I'll try to answer them to best
of my ability
and with that
I am going to um
go ahead and start
the segment that we recorded in August
INE science he just says
he spent his summer teaching uh
Analytics
for the Carlson school so this
expression is mine welcome
Brian Campbell it's one of our expert
instructors uh course advisors for
simply learning business analytics agile
and scrum
sorry
business agile transformation coach
teacher
teacher special corporations especially
around Houston where he's based
Helen gas sector he's been working with
simple design from five years and he
will take us through the actual learning
environment
welcome Brian
start
business analytics as a career
the business analysis and the analytic
skills are more essential than ever
we've gone through
period in the last two years
extremely rapid digital transformation
driven by the fact
that what we do has to go into the
digital domain for a time we were not
allowed to meet the ice
people in our offices
people we
dealt with his vendors and customers all
had to shift into
digital domain
is created
even more data
about business operations are
transactions our relationships
the way our machines work from
on Factory floors or
things
and this
this portion of information
contains a lot of weaving but
you have to extract the information from
the data
collection can you talk more about this
specialty
so I would fully Echo what Stuart was
saying we are definitely witnessing a
dramatic increase in the use of business
analytics in all functional areas of
business and different companies
uh there's really a wave of physical
transformation powered by the abundance
of data that organizations collect as
well as their capabilities capabilities
of analyzing that data to generate
actionable insight to support decision
making and strategy development to give
you an example I as a faculty member at
Carlson school I teach the business
master master of science in business
analytics program this is a full-time
program and as part of the program
students work with real companies to
solve a business analytics question
about three four years ago the kind of
clients that we get who have this
analytics need are mostly large
technically sophisticated companies
these days we get all kinds of clients
sometimes even very small companies with
30 to 40 employees trying to Leverage
analytics capability to generate
insights so that they can you know do
better business or do better marketing
Outreach or do better supply chain
optimization so this is uh penetrating
almost every functional domain of
believe that I am aware of so this is
brilliant that store speaking to
small restaurants
that's a way to avoid physical menus as
a
um
disease transmission control
culture
all of those interactions and digital
[Music]
information
these restaurants that use especially if
they're part of a small chain
the customers and buying patterns and
patterns and
generate once you
have walls that are available
just reflects that we had a number of
different career paths do some
average salary failures but the upper
limits on the insert
much much higher
business analyst probably qualified
takes an average of 81 000.
that's
going to be higher in some regions lower
in others but as you get past the
average and into higher levels of your
career
it's far far higher same thing with
project managers data analysts
a market research analysts these are
just a few of the different roles
new trajectories that
the
analytics expertise
Clearfield so
do that you really have to have
a suite of skills
address some of this in terms of
that are this program
talking about today
give to the learners
yeah so you know as you're highlighting
here what makes I think business
analysis in and of itself interesting is
it draws Upon A Range a wide range of
different skills so uh things like you
know your problem solving and your
analytical skills I think are sort of
well recognized as uh
I mean but oftentimes you're also
leveraging a lot of very Cutting Edge
technical tools and products we've heard
motion sort of share that about deep
learning the AI and pattern all this
Rich data trying to make sense of it and
the communication skills oftentimes as a
business analyst you're the one
presenting this information
organizational leadership uh helping
them make good and informed decisions so
uh that involves strategic analysis and
understanding the directions that
organizations need to take so it's um
it's really exciting and I think a
highly fulfilling field as a result you
can see it's such a rich opportunity to
kind of participate in so many different
parts of that business analysis space
we we had a
talk from a sales force data scientist
some time ago we talked about
challenges of decision support
business analytics falls into that
um talking about how some problems come
to you from the business side where we
need to understand this better what's
the solution
in some cases it's the other way around
where you is the uh for Linux
realize that there's ways
extract certain insights that maybe
management has thought of so you go to
them and say hey if you knew about this
would that help
the business so it's a very Dynamic
field
that respect
at this point what I'd like to do is I
would like to run a poll for the
audience and
we're looking at the poll question here
start this poll here
and you have
about 30 seconds left to answer the
question
what is the reason that you haven't
engaged in a program of this type so far
if you're if you're interested in
becoming a expert in business analyst
analysis rather or starting a career as
a business analyst
what has stopped you so far from not
from
getting into a program like this and
getting that that path started for
yourself
we'll keep this open for about another
10 seconds
and coming up here is the result
and
by far the the most popular answer if I
can say it that way is uh
you don't feel that you would have
practical experience that you'd be able
to show off to your employer or to a
potential future employer to say yes I
have done this type of work and here are
examples of how I've done it
um so with that go on and look at how
the program
gets you
over that objection so
let's continue
foreign
to it about 10 to 15 hours a week
There's weekly classes that are live
online
and
you'll need to attend a certain
percentage of those in order to program
but um
it's flexible enough that you can do all
the other work on your own time on the
24 7
digital platform that we provide that
Brian's going to demonstrate
um design the program
which Carlson schools designed to
collaboration with IBM so that some of
the modules are
IBM instructors their master classes
with IBM and you'll receive IBN
certificates for some of the courses
talk a little bit later about
how this is built in
my step series of courses that take you
from
being a novice or newcomer field to the
whole expertise
along the way you do
studies Hands-On projects that will
allow you to
YouTube
skills and the use of the tools that
we're introducing the gain confidence
with all the skills together in a
Capstone project
under the direction of an instructor
Ryan who will
be that last
four week process
along the way as I mentioned you take
live
online
with your instructors
um
you have the opportunity to interact
with the instructor and
with us
so that it's not a one-way transmission
of
exchange of knowledge
this is all uh signed on a
digital platform 24x7 availability 24x7
support
so that if you're working on a homework
or
project assignment between classes
you have the ability to draw on
your years for advice or contact the
instructor contact or others
technical or object matter support staff
through those bumps so
all right I know we're going to be going
to you for a tour of the system in a bit
but I have a flavor of what it's like to
take
them absolutely and I think you really
kind of put on some of the key aspects
that make this a really compelling
um offering you know versus that
flexibility you know the the person
that's also balancing you know work
commitments and personal
responsibilities
um this really fits nicely into that
um those Pockets you have throughout the
day you kind of shift and make your uh
you know make the priorities that you
need uh kind of fit with the delivery
schedule uh the the thing and we're
going to see this firsthand and I'm kind
of excited to show that to you um it's
got a really easy navigation around it
so it's so easy to both get in to get
the information you need progress
through some of the content if you need
to you can pause you can come back to it
um so all that flexibility I think
really lends itself to the way that
people learn these days
um you know I think very few of us have
the ability to kind of sequester elves
for you know full days week out a week
and learning something we need to be
able to kind of pull it when we need it
absorb it look for opportunities to
apply it and then as you highlight it
too I find the mentoring the coaching
part working with people like mocha and
myself learning how not just to
understand these Concepts how to apply
them in a real world business setting so
um yeah lots of lots of exciting uh
features to this program that we'll be
digging into shortly
and as as merchant said
element of
real world
to describe the
other program that
Carlson school
um
or
advanced
working directly with companies online
this program emulates that because
once that came up from live companies
To God Be interacting with people
yeah predicting with your instructors as
if they were your boss at that company
finding you a problem to solve
really gives you that the kind of live
type practical experience as I mentioned
certificates from several courses in
this
[Music]
related
or sorry
simply when generated uh
uh generated and the ultimate completion
of the course is certified by
University of Minnesota Carlson school
so
certifying Authority that's going to say
yes you completed
program
all the requirements demonstrated all
the skills
we're going to vouch for your skills
to get that
certificate once you've completed the
course you get certificates along the
way
for an elected person tag
is appropriate and then
participation with
IBM and
Carlson school is great because you get
not just the interactions master classes
with me
awesome professors like budget
but also yet interactions with IBM
Personnel hackathons ask me anything
you have the ability to get a flavor for
what's going on in Industry what are the
trends or some real
world and
two benefits
are
Association
I have the ability network with
who've gone through similar programs
girls in school
that's a great lifetime career building
opportunity we also give you a
women's job assist program and I'll
think about that
gives you
specific services to help
job search so
you're making us to move up your career
some of those services will apply if
you're taking this to move into a new
career or
a job maybe with a new employer uh
the parts of the services will apply and
we'll talk about that
so uh
touching can you speak to
the history and reputation of the
Carlson School
University of Minnesota
totally happy to uh so first of all we
are very excited to be partnered with us
simply learn on this program so as I
mentioned before and from the Carlson
School of Management and University of
Minnesota we have a very long history we
just celebrated our Centennial a couple
of years ago more importantly we're also
a modern place we have world-class
faculty members and instructional
instructional uh you know faculty
members in across across you know
multiple big week programs and I want to
give you instead of these you know very
abstract numbers I want to give you a
very direct sense of who you will be
interacting with from Carlson school so
throughout the six month uh duration of
the program that hopefully you will
consider enrolling uh my understanding
is that every every month uh there will
be a master class uh delivered by uh one
of three faculty members from across the
school including me and two of my
colleagues of my colleagues that I will
introduce later there's three of us come
from the information physician science
department within the Carlson school and
this is actually the number one uh
Department ranked Nationwide in terms of
research publication in the area of
machine learning and information systems
based on based on you know Association
of Information Systems ranking from 2017
to 2019. the reason I mentioned that is
because
we believe we can bring you the direct
expertise in data science machine
learning business analytics and business
decision making
digital transformation all these areas
because we're actually uh part of the
community that's at the Forefront of
developing some of the tools that
companies are using and applying to
solve their daily data science problems
at the same time we also work very
closely with companies to solve the
problems through the different programs
and Industry collaborations that I
mentioned earlier in terms of reputation
Carlson School of Management is one of
the best public school uh public
Business Schools in the nation and you
know
you know there are you know a lot of
rankings that you can look up online but
I want to give you sort of the more
human touch of it in fact it is not only
recognized within the U.S United States
it is also internationally uh recognized
among the master degree programs uh in
different departments we routinely have
over 50 percent International represent
international student representation in
a student body in the undergrad program
the ratio is lower but still uh
significant I believe last time I
checked is around 20 30 international
student which means that uh you know
students recognize House of school as a
prestigious institutions not only come
within the University United States but
also from all around the world and I
know that the audience uh and sort of
the potential enrollees of Simply learn
also come from
that perspective
think having Carlson's School of
Management
on your CV and on on your certificate is
going to give you a big advantage in
terms of career placement and in terms
of career advancement
so thank you
on behalf of on behalf of my colleagues
and Carlson School of Management we're
really excited about this partnership
and we want to welcome you formally into
the program in a in you know shortly
perfect thank you so much
and
at this point I'm going to um
share with you some of the material
live so that we don't have to go through
the recording part
let me just check one quick thing
where we continue
so one of the benefits that the
you saw mentioned
is simply learned career assist service
the program lasts for six months but for
six months after you earn your
certificate
simply learn works with you to help you
focus your job search and help you
prepare
to
differentiate yourself out in the job
market
we do that in partnership with Talent
Inc this is for students who are in the
United States
and we have a few things that we do in
addition we also give you access to
ongoing a series of expert webinars that
talk about career and Technology topics
we also help you build up your portfolio
of projects through the program itself
but let me talk about the talent Inc
Career Services job assist services
one aspect is an exclusive job portal
Talent Inc runs called resume rabbit and
this gives you the ability to discreetly
access a network of unique jobs for
employers
that work with Talent Inc
um
that is not as valuable in my mind as
the other two Services one is resume
rewrite
uh
the top resume service gives you the
ability to work with a resume writer who
will help you optimize your resume and
this is important because in today's
world
we um
excuse me checking my
microphone setting here you go today's
world your resume goes to an automated
resume tracking system before it ever
goes to a human being so an AI bot is
going to check your resume for things
like keywords and phrases matching up to
the job description from the employer
uh being able to format your resume in a
way that
passes through that filter but then also
continues to appear attractive to the
human eye when it gets to somebody's
desk or desktop is an important almost
art form so
to be able to put your best foot forward
in terms of your resume in the written
content
this service is extremely valuable
um on the other hand is the one-on-one
interview service because
once you get through the resume
screening process and get a phone call
or an email that says like to talk to
you then you'll need to interact with
people face to face whether that's in
person or whether that's over Skype
that's going to be
direct human interaction and you have to
be able to
carry out a couple kinds of interviews
one is
technical interviews that talk about
your debt business analysis skills in
particular technical issues other is
managerial or team building resident
interview rather that talks about your
ability to be a team player about your
ability to get along with others about
your ability to take Direction all of
the soft skills that are important
as an employee so the one-on-one
interview service prep talks to you
about both types of interviews gives you
practice sessions in both scenarios
lets you get some career coaching and
helps you to present yourself in the
best light when you're doing that kind
of in-person interaction so
those are valuable Services again they
continue for six months after you
receive your certificate it's not a job
guarantee or placement service it is a
career and job search preparation
service
I mentioned the expert webinars we do uh
weekly
several webinars some of them are this
type that you're watching now but some
of them are
General informational webinars about how
to conduct a career search what next
steps you should take in your career
what trends are coming up in
different Technologies or technological
subjects and even some
sample classes
learning a particular skill a mini
lesson that lasts an hour so
these are all free to you and they
continue lifelong
and your projects that you develop
during the boot camp itself are also
part of your portfolio something that
you can take with you and keep with you
for the long run and show off to
potential employers or demonstrate to
your current employer this is what I've
learned this is how I've applied these
skills these are the classes of problems
I'm now
qualified to solve for you so
this is extremely valuable in terms of
your
your job search and your career
development
now when we talk about eligibility for
this program it is a postgraduate
program meaning that you have to have a
bachelor's degree it can be in any
discipline it does not have to be in
business does not have to be in
engineering does not have to be in
technology it can be in any degree
with at least a GPA of 2.0 50 marks for
unless we go outside the U.S you do need
a or we prefer that you have at least
two years of work experience it's
possible to succeed in this program
without experience you can come straight
out of a university or college but we do
recommend that you have some exposure to
the Working World and then you need a
drive to apply business analytics to
real world problems
so you need to have the aptitude and the
desire to use business analytics
um
so we'll ask the question now how many
years of experience do you currently
have in the workforce and again this is
not in business analytics particularly
it's not in the particular area just how
many years of experience do you have
leave this open for another 10 seconds
or so
pretty straightforward question
and I'll close the poll
and we have a pretty seasoned audience
tonight more than half the people who
responded said they have more than 10
years of experience the next largest
sector about a quarter who said less
than two years so
again this program is designed to help
people who uh
are at every level of experience but we
do prefer that you have more than two
years so if you've got less than two
years you'll want to talk to our
learning counselors
and evaluate if this program is right
for you if you
higher categories definitely it's a
great program to add skills to your
personal toolkit or to Pivot into
business Analytics
so
I'm going to um
move on and we have another
recorded segment that I'll do
just a moment
moment while we're doing that
all right
so
back to uh Brian Campbell and Professor
Motrin yang
it's really going to give you everything
from the foundational fundamentals up
through that progression and how do you
apply these techniques into more you
know Progressive demanding real world
environments if you're already bringing
some experience into this space
um I think you're going to find this as
a great opportunity to kind of enrich
what you already know one of the things
that really appeals to me about this
program as an instructor is it gives me
a chance to connect with students in all
ranges and sort of experiences so some
are are you know bringing in deeper
issues and problems that they're working
on because they've been in that domain a
little longer and spending time with
them is often really helpful because it
allows them to kind of bring some
different experiences into how they
solve these problems but for for folks
are a little new to this too I mean we
we all need to start somewhere and even
those of us a little bit more
experienced it can be very valuable to
kind of get those Refreshers and to come
back to topics that we need to revisit
so we can apply a little more
effectively so it's it's very well
structured I do know that's uh I'm sure
uh motion was uh involved in how do we
design a course that kind of connects
all these different experience arranges
together and I think it really you'll
see this when we start looking at the
course content shortly
and
just one observation before your cue to
start sharing your screen which is um
you know one of the aspects of people
who are experienced to come into courses
like this sometimes they're coming in
just pivot from a different field
um
and just in general
how is this
worked out for people who don't have
that
data background analytics background
we're looking to break into the area
yeah another great question and I think
it you know you kind of highlighted
something that is I think important for
everyone that's listening in here
participating today you know there is
something about having that innate
passion if this is something that
interests you you really want to kind of
learn more about and make that pivot
that shift uh I think that part's uh
really important and if you're bringing
that energy into the program I think
you're going to rapidly discover okay
here's all the different tools that are
going to enable your success so um the
way it's structured it it does start
with the foundations we're going to make
sure that you're in a really solid place
to kind of start expanding uh your
knowledge and developing those skills so
if you're bringing with you a lot of
organizational experience that's gonna
be really valuable
um actually that's those are the parts
of the course that are a little harder
to teach so you're going to get a lot of
benefit from just having some of that
practical experience to Leverage
right and so if you would rank and you
share with us what it looked like for
Learners in the learning management
system you bet all right let me just get
my screen here for you
let me know if you can see this
yep
awesome okay so um
as Stewart said one of the more
important aspects of this program my
opinion is a learning management system
itself the LMS I said I've already
logged into the learning simply learn
Learning Management platform as you can
see right off the bat we've got a number
of these tiles that we can click on to
start digging into the different
programs let's of course start with the
umn business analytics bootcamp we click
on this and immediately it brings you
into the course structure itself
and hopefully you can see that this is
all pretty easy to navigate very uh nice
um user interface that they've spent a
lot of time developing simply learn has
been doing this for a very long time I
don't even know how many folks have been
through all the different courses simply
learn has but wouldn't surprise me say
it's hundreds of thousands and all that
has allowed to learn to really think
carefully about the best way to engage
people through that learning interface
so um you can see here we see when the
session starts we've got our orientation
session if we scroll down we can see the
different courses that are offered as
part of the program now this steps you
through a sequence a dimension there's
some foundational level information
that's really important that we make
sure we were comfortable with that we
can use to progress into the other parts
of the program
and if we click on one of these let's
just get a little uh view of of what
that looks like
and we can see right off the bat we have
a series of well-structured lessons with
descriptions and chapters each one is
supported by videos with industry
leading and an expert instructors giving
you the the course overview you can
progress these at your own pace you can
see the standard video controls at the
bottom where you can fast forward you
can zoom into certain parts of the
course you can pause leave the course
come back it will remember where you
left off so that's kind of convenient if
you've got some limited cycles and kind
of go through some some of the material
and you get interrupted you have to come
back to a later Point
um I particularly like the fact that you
can easily go you know through the
content pick those areas that maybe you
need to spend a little bit more time
with or maybe our topics you you know
little more interested in spending a bit
more time on so this is sort of a sort
of the layout of the of the course
modules themselves each one of the
courses also are going to have some
resources you can access in this case
this is the course content itself you
simply click on the ebook there you can
see it's starting to download we open
that up here's all the course content
all the material that you have so this
makes it very easy to kind of take this
offline or look at later if you want to
go a bit deeper into any of the topics
you covered
you'll also see these assessments you've
taken the course now let's test how much
of that we're able to retain and these
are again
self-paced so you decide when to take
your assessment
and once you click on that take it now
you'll see that uh you get a question do
you really want to start it I'm going to
be bold and set it up and we start
getting questions you get a timer and at
the end of this you'll get a chance to
get your evaluation
this gives you a little sense of how
well you've been able to absorb the
information and if you do have questions
issues maybe there's some areas topics
that you want to go back to you can
bring yourself back to the self-learning
look at those again and when this is all
said and done you're going to get an
opportunity to get a certificate of
completion
again another great way to kind of track
your progress towards getting your uh
your final
postgraduate recognition
we unlock these doing a certain amount
of activities that again or tracked in
the learning platform itself
and um a few other things just to kind
of highlight for you that I think are
important one is you can see that you
know I haven't completed all these
things I'm not ready to move on to the
next section so this is a way in which
we can ensure that everyone's
progressing at the same pace and making
sure they've got the right foundation
but we've also gotten some prerequisites
before you start
um here's some fundamentals if you want
to spend a little time making sure
you're comfortable with before jumping
into the the course itself and there's
also a collection of electives and these
electives cover a range of different
topics and give you an opportunity to
kind of explore some other areas of the
program
um that interests you or you think would
perhaps help and support your your
career so uh so that's sort of a high
level here one of the things that I know
you've brought up are Eddie um Stuart
but I do want to kind of bring us back
to is the Capstone project I know some
of you shared hey I'm a little early in
my career I don't have a lot of the
experience that's going to let me make
this shift into this space well this is
where the business analyst Capstone
project comes in these are case study
driven they're very contemporary real
world topics that you are going to get a
chance to pick one that kind of relates
to you you're going to get a chance to
kind of work through a set of problems
that are going to again feel very
similar to what organizations are
interested in answering and then you'll
get help along the way from your
instructors but also an evaluation on
your uh your work so you can learn from
that and this ultimately becomes
something you can bring in to
conversations interviews just any time
you're kind of making that you know next
step in your career progression this
becomes something you can look back at
and in a reference so I think that's a
real highlight of the program
so with that uh Stuart I don't know if
there's anything else
you want to spend time on here
yeah a little bit I know that you're not
able to go
next module in the sequence because you
haven't completed the introductory of
course but in the other modules you also
have the interface of the live classes
yeah you know I'm glad you brought that
up one thing um you know the self-paced
part of this is really quite important
and gives a lot of flexibility to people
on how they learn when they learn but
there's also live instructor-led
sessions available for all of these you
can roll in
and be part of sort of a conversation a
little like this where can people like
myself moach and others uh the other
thing to bring to your attention that I
also think is really powerful is simple
garden has a great um you know community
space where you will be connecting with
your peers in the program talking about
work they've done asking questions
instructors are available this is also a
somebody 24 availabilities so no matter
where you are in the world you can pop
some questions in there's there's
instructors always kind of monitoring
this and I find it really kind of helps
create that virtual sense of community
um and one thing I would also mention
about the uh
platform itself it manages your progress
through the courses you have tools like
for example with the live class schedule
you can add
class dates to your
Outlook or Google Calendar
get reminders out at the LMS
tender classes
the system will send you props and
pushes to invite you along if you're
getting
behind in the coursework
um so it's designed to support you for
success keep you on track and get you
that end point successfully
all the skills that
need to be successful in your new career
so um
did I get basically all of that right
yeah I nailed it and I think that's a
you know just just again personal uh you
know sharing here but you know I have a
chance to work with a lot of different
organizations and including learning
organizations simpler and I can share
with you this is by far and away the
best LMS that is available on the market
I can speak highly enough of it and I've
seen a lot of these products out there
um so yeah it is really positioned and I
think that was the vision that simply
learn had from the get-go how do we
leverage our platform to ensure the
success of our participants
very good thank you for that uh tour of
the learning management system and I'm
going to
go back to our
presentation
and so I'm going to ask Munchen to
talk a little bit about how we
constructed the program
why hey Carlson school put this
particular series of classes in the
sequences as you saw with Brian's
demonstration you can't move to the next
step up in the program until you finish
stuff that you're on that's to make sure
that you are
prepared to succeed in that next course
and not skipping ahead of them
capabilities
the
um you would mention if you speak to the
circus absolutely uh glad to so uh the
curriculum that across the school put
together uh in collaboration with
learning that you're seeing on the
screen now is really a very uh sensible
and you know sensible you know
collection of steps that you need to
follow through in order to build a solid
foundation and skill set in business
analytics so let me give you some
details the course on the bottom this is
uh uh introduction to data analytics
this is one of the foundational
introductory courses that you will learn
which gives you a broad sense of what is
business analytics what is data
analytics what exactly are you trying to
achieve and expose you to different
types of analytics different types of
tasks uh or you know different flavors
of machine learning analytics tasks that
uh you know uh and and also in terms of
the different kinds of values that they
deliver different kinds of problems
they're designed to solve so this is
really a conceptual oriented course that
gives you the idea and the landscape of
data analytics and once you complete
that course you will dive into uh you
know different kinds of tools that
really teach you to tackle and analyze
data from different perspective so
business analytics with Excel that
should be familiar to you know uh many
of you Excel is a really powerful but
also a little bit rudimentary tool in a
sense that allows you to do a lot of
analysis but you also need additional
capability uh
so once you progress after Excel you'll
be looking at SQL this is one of the
most popular database languages
it allows you to handle and query very
large amounts of data as actually you
know among all the organizations I've
worked with you know all of them are
using some form of database to store
their data and you need to use SQL
language to really extract information
from that
and then our programming for data
science R is a very popular data science
programming language that allows you to
run a variety of different analysis both
in machine learning and statistical
inference
and this course will give you the
foundation for that and data analytics
with our actually this this part I would
need some help from Stuart or Brian in
terms of the difference between these
two courses I'm guessing our programming
is more geared towards uh the basics of
programming related tasks whereas data
analytics is more application oriented
using R to solve specific data analytics
problems but please correct me and if
I'm mistaken here
okay yeah these are also these are also
examples of the IBM
but these
particular courses you will receive IBM
certificates on completing those modules
so that's an example of how we
integrated in the Partnerships yeah
and then data visualization with Tableau
Tableau is probably the most popular uh
one of the two most popular
visualization tools dashboarding tools
in the industry and you will you will be
learning how to how to basically convert
both extract insights from visualization
and also communicate the insights to
management to stakeholders using
visualization tools and dashboards in
Tableau and then the last two components
are basically Capstone programs you know
where you will be working with real
clients on real problems and which
Stuart mentioned earlier so if you look
at the progression of different courses
this is really how you know people
actually approach analytics problems in
reality you start with data extraction
using SQL you you know then you use some
kind of programming languages such as r
or python to try to manipulate the data
analyze the data run some kind of
statistical or machine learning models
generate the insights and then you try
to communicate the insights using some
kind of visual tools or report in
dashboard such as or power bi so all of
that is recovered in this curriculum
you see down at the lower right a series
of electives which are
take based on your level of interest in
your time availability
um none of them are at any additional
costs so they're all treated to attend
as part of the program
and they include those very important
master classes but
Richard and his colleagues
or else in school but also from industry
experts from IBM so we encourage of
course all of our students to take full
advantage of the elected
again to complete the program and get
their certificate you need to complete
the stair step courses in the core
um the electives are just that electives
he's learning different tools and
Frameworks here's a sampling of types of
tools that that you'll be exposed to and
practicing with
um so as much mentioned
Excel Tableau power bi you'll be
learning the r language and some of the
Python language and you'll be training
in how to use SQL SQL or data extraction
queries so all of these are
tools and Frameworks that not only would
you learn about learn how to use
do actual exercises
integrated online lab part of the
funding management system
you don't have to go out and buy
separate software to deal with any of
these These are within the
learning management system
about section
we keep referring to the Capstone
project because it's really an important
project uh
part of this course
um again
this is where you take a real world
business problem
uh opposed to you the way an employer
would post it to you and you take time
to solve this problem with the skills
that you require during the program
under the mentorship of somebody like
Ryan who is going to uh weekly to
monitor your progress on the Capstone
help you with any
kinds of questions or blockers
dots that you might have about
how you're going or
how many blocks that you might have run
into
this way you'll get through the Capstone
project and result again something that
is in your portfolio
take away with you and show off to the
real world uh people you're going to be
talking to so
we structure our multi course programs
in this way because
it's not enough just to
pick off the skills that you're going to
get at each of the steps in the program
it's important to understand
demonstrate that you can use all of
those skills and tools together in a
coherent problem solving exercise so
as merchant mentioned he's got
colleagues along with himself who will
be leading master classes and I will he
knows them far better than I'll let him
describe
sure happy too so the three of us uh our
faculty members from Carlson school we
will be in charge of delivering the
master classes uh once per month as far
as
based on my understanding these specific
topics of the master classes have not
been fully determined yet uh but what I
know for now is that I will be
delivering webmaster classes on ethical
considerations in machine learning such
as fairness issues and algorithmic bias
and two of my colleagues Ravi bhatna and
Guinness Adam mobile truth are both
co-professors they are experts in the
data science domain Ravi for example is
an leading expert in working with
companies and using experimental methods
to uh you know to really do testing and
derive strategic insights such as
randomized experiments or a B testings
um get us on the other hand is a machine
learning expert uh he also has a very
deep expertise in recommender system
which is actually the algorithm behind
large companies such as Google Netflix
and Amazon you know on almost all of the
large tech companies that you ever heard
so uh just to give you one anecdote he
is uh actually the author one of the
authors of the most highly cited
recommender system paper in that in that
notebook so all of us are you know uh
experts in the in in the area and we'll
be happy to deliver the master classes
to you
great thank you
and at this point we have another poll
and
this one's pretty straightforward
we're asking based on what you've seen
and heard so far are you interested in
enrolling in the program
so this was your only
leave open for about 15 seconds or so
okay
and about a third of our audience is
interested so that's a good number and
let's
move on to the last part of our
webinar tonight
I'll share with you the steps for
enrollment for those of you who are
interested
straightforward process you email us at
ask us at simply learn
.net I will put that email address into
the chat box
along with the URL for the program page
and
you'll be able to access that directly
all right
and that's there
so your emails ask us at simplylearn.net
there will be an application review
there will be some interaction with our
learning Consultants
evaluating your aptitude and interest in
business analytics of verifying your
academic background your work history
and if you pass the application review
you'll get an admission offer
and the next class cohort starts in the
week on December 20th uh it's not a
class to start I should say that is the
orientation session the actual classes
for that cohort don't start until March
so you have plenty of time
but if you would like to get started
please do
email us at ask us at simplylearn.net
again the program cost is eight thousand
dollars U.S can be financed out at seven
hundred dollars uh 704 a month
and
one other quick question
if you are interested are you interested
in joining that next cohort or something
further down the road
here we go
all right
and
so for those of you who said you were
interested looks like most of you are
interested in doing it quickly
again within uh
joined the
orientation session either on the 20th
or there will be another orientation
soon thereafter for that same March 4th
cohort of classes starting
so
at this point I am going to go ahead
and take your questions
and
I do have some of the responses that
and much on rather and Brian gave to the
other session that they did in August
but like to start with your questions
because
you're here live
um
so
I will put into the chat before we move
on the LinkedIn addresses for both
motion Yang and Brian Campbell and that
way
you'll be able to reach out to them with
anything that I haven't been able to
answer for you
um
ajabula asks how does business analytics
business intelligence differ in the real
world so business intelligence is
essentially
the applied version of business
analytics where business analytics can
be done for various reasons including
operational reasons but business
intelligence synthesizes
that result into
actionable actionable advice for
business management to
they're very interested uh
intimately intertwined
forgive my uh assembling a speech but um
business analytics feeds into business
intelligence it's not necessarily
identical to it though
um Simon Sima asks can a foreign medical
graduate no prior knowledge of coding or
hardcore mathematics survive this course
and yes the answer is and may have
caught it a little bit during Brian's
presentation of the learning management
system but the course includes
Refreshers and basic parameter courses
on uh coding in mathematics as necessary
if you need those to
give yourself a little bit of a
foundation going into the program so you
have the tools that you'll need to
succeed uh even if you don't come in
with coding or mathematics background
um very important
that we structure the course that way so
that it's open up to as many people as
possible and the first presumption here
is that if you have successfully
completed a college degree you have the
demonstrated skills and
intention that will let you
take on new courses of study and you uh
subject areas and succeed with them so
Divine ass related question do you need
a master's degree to study analytics and
the answer of course is no we do require
a bachelor's degree but not a
postgraduate degree Master's or
doctorate
um
George asked an interesting question
which is that he does not want to work
for a big company uh he'd rather work as
an independent data analytics and
being an adolescent consultant and this
is a good way to get started into that
path George because it will give you the
um
data analytics background that says here
that you've done a boot camp at Rutgers
um
and
you probably would like to talk to I
think learning consultants and take a
look at the uh web page for our course
to see how it compares to what you've
already done and see if it's going to
give you the additional value to move
your career ahead because that's one of
the things you've said here is that
you've
um been having difficulty finding a path
to apply what you learned in that other
boot camp so
um please do talk to us about that you
can also reach out to motion through the
his LinkedIn page and ask him personally
for information
you can also look at some of the other
programs available through simply learn
if
your
um interest is in data analytics as
opposed to business analytics so you
have a lot of different options for you
um
akshit asks
is it necessary to have experience as a
business analyst prior to this program
uh actually you do not have to have
prior business analytics experience
um you in fact coming in from a
different field
um and adding this set of skills to what
you know and your existing domain
just gives you an advantage over other
people who are working in that same
domain with you so this is a a good
opportunity for people who want to
apply to data analytics or business
analytics in their existing domain or
who want to Pivot into business
analytics uh George also asks do you
offer job placement in this
as I described
the
job assist program is not a job
placement program it's a program to help
you focus your job search and prepare
for it better but we don't
offer any particular placement or
guarantee of a job so
um how would this class help me to
become an independent I think I
discovered that for you George
um
and
I think those are all the questions that
have come in from our audience
so at this point I'm going to
go to a final question for you all
and
that question is this
if you are interested in enrolling do
you need assistance can we
help you get this process started
I'll leave this open for a few more
seconds
all right and closing the poll
so as in previously about a third of the
folks who answered said that they would
like some assistance the best way to get
that is to go to that email address I
shared with you which is ask us
simplylearn.net
if you want to scan that QR code it will
take you to the program page on our
website
and
I want to thank everybody who came out
tonight for this webinar we appreciate
your being here and we hope we can
welcome you into the Carlson School
University of Minnesota Learning
Community with us
so that concludes the webinar for this
evening thank you very much
have a great rest of your evening